nous avons pris l'accueil chez la
voisine pour entrer chez maria pacôme il
ya quatre ans cette dernière en nous
présentant canaille sa chaîne avait été
l'une des premières à accueillir 30
millions d'amis tél
depuis maria pacôme a poursuivi sa route
deux comédiennes plus une allée
parallèle celle d'auteur dramatique avec
apprend - c'est di maria est venu nous
rejoindre une nouvelle fois il fait beau
cannell existe toujours une franche et
ses quatre années écoulées c'est déjà
autre fois qu'il agissait le président
elle est là la cour bien à la cannelle
et l'art attend ça doit lui faire 11 ans
elle va avoir onze ans
peu avant 11 ans mois de décembre 11 ans
nés ici cannelle du mineur va sauter
comme des yes i can elle vient ici bien
se parlent de toi oui celle-là elle
vieillit pas trop mal encore alors je la
regarde et puis quand même à la 11 ans
et pète 11 ans et sa voix pourquoi là
encore le poids d'une certaine manière
c'est assez rassurant que que vous belle
kelly tout bien hein alors à l'époque
vous nous aviez parlé de canal en ces
termes
rappelez vous je l'aimais colère voilà
juste une chaîne qui complètement brand
que lé voleuse
elle ouvre les portes l abîme tout non
mais truffé rhodoïd alors là je n'ai
même plus joli jardin
alors parce qu'elle saute par dessus la
barre yalala prêt aussi à sauter par
dessus la barrière
elle est tellement turbulente est
tellement instable je suis en train de
la noircir pauvres bêtes pour canet long
l'adorent c'est pas tout de donner la
patte et de la caresser il faut savoir
aussi se faire obéir et la chine n'en
serait que mieux
elle en serait plus équilibrée
certainement c'est pas elle qui est
fautif c'est nous
alors aujourd'hui les maîtres ont ils
fait des progrès et cannelle at elle
rachetait le mal qu'elle a fait aux
platebandes aucun ace cannelle on aime
toujours bien sûr mais toujours d'une
manière désordonnée quoi elle avait fait
beaucoup de grabuge eux ça c'est pas
tellement amélioré ma vie à la 4 ans et
plus
moi aussi j'ai vieillit peut-être que je
suis plus patiente donc il ya une chose
un cannes elle ya là ma fille je les
fais opérer enfin je n'ai pas fait
opérer moi parce que moi j'étais pas
tellement d'accord on a voulu parce
qu'elle elle faisait grossesse nerveuse
s'il n'avait pas été opéré ce que vous
l'auriez les ces demoiselles
avant j'aurais eu l'occasion sans doute
se mange pas là jamais voulu se souvenir
un chien était bien la fin beauregard
elle s'est carapaté et a rien eu à faire
alors voilà aller comme ça maintenant
cannelle est le suis plus patiente avec
quelques angles elle ouvre toujours les
portes mais je me suis arrangé j'ai
changé un peu les serrures
je regarde ça d'une manière plus
attendri parce que d'abord comme elle
vieillit je la regarde j'ai quand même
vous pouviez la rencontre heureuse
moi j'aurais peut être à la place de
koné notre idée de vous en débarrasser
par un moyen ou par un autre vous est
elle venue quelque chose ça mais aussi
dans des mouvements de colère que cette
chienne mais je m'en débarrasse il veut
pas la garder en fait jamais sitôt
qu'elle a un petit truc qu'on appelle le
vétérinaire l'a dernièrement on lui fait
des séries de piqûres possède l'eczéma
cet imbécile et plus que ça l eczéma
alors j'ai même eu à cause d'elle on m'a
fait une piqûre antitétanique actuelle
mesure parce que la chaise du revenu de
vacances
la chaîne a vu de l'excès ma vie de vie
du téléphone le vétérinaire en la
traînant dans la boue bien sûr pour abc
il filme à l'eczéma maintenant et là la
fouine l'est pas encore vu la petite
chapelle est marrante
alors elle avait aussi d'eczéma alors on
a piqué cannelle pour mes piqûres contre
ça puis le vétérinaire a voulu prendre
la petite la fouine et elle s'est
accrochée à moi et alluma mes griffes et
sa saignée et bien j'ai une piqûre
antitétanique quel courage des trois
plis ké quoi
maria que pensez-vous du phénomène
abandon des animaux domestiques et en
règle générale du mal qui est fait aux
animaux quelque soit ce que je trouve
odieux mais ça ça je peux pas l'accepter
bon admettons que moi j'aime aller les
animaux mu serait incapable et un cas ce
que des gens puissent abandonner un
animal quand ils partent en vacances
mois pour moi alors là c'est une chose
qui me révolte totalement jeudi les gens
qui font ça et je le dis sont capables
de tout ils sont capables quand on fait
ça et dieu sait si j'ai pas une mémère à
chien chien ni hh à ninon faire ça c'est
une chose qui me tient ferme en fait
qu'à ça me fait hérisser le poil c'est
pas possible c'est honteux
ces lâches et ces gens là hélas il y en
a beaucoup beaucoup et j'en cherche un
kiné qui m'a vous qui me dise en face
j'ai osé abandonner une bête
y'en a pas un animal ça se garde ça se
soigne mais ne pensez vous pas qu'il ya
trop de chiens trop de chats c'est la
solitude 1 je crois qu'elle nous en
veille beaucoup je crois que les gens
ont envie d'être rassuré c'est ça ils
sont rassurés par un animal peut-être
plus qu'avant
je pense enfin saint cannat davantage
c'est peut-être de la science fiction
mais pouvez vous imaginer qu'un jour
tous les animaux pourraient se venger
dans une sorte de grande corrida finale
dont il sortirait vainqueur
ces quatre os foule
quelle horreur j'ai bien là mignotte et
cannelle on sait jamais
s'il devait revenir un jour oui après sa
mort un à l'arc sous quelle forme
l'animal soit auriez vous la voir le
revoir chouette ce que j'ai d'abord je
dors les chouettes c'est toujours aimé
j'en ai une
et puis il n'ya pas dire c'est quand
même moins encombrant c'est très marrant
c'est fascinant
je reviendrai et puis vous en parler
pendant au moins deux heures ma chouette
elle était super quelle est la musique
finale qui lui serait le mieux la
personnalité de cannelle musique un
morceau de musique les admire
et